you're seeing protests all around and
there's a difference between
the protests okay they're the protests
at the school boards with the parents
protesting crt and the gender stuff and
the vaccine mandates and all the rest of
it
and then there are
the fake protests
there are the astroturf protests
the court jester protests that's what
you saw
at the big climate conference
with greta thunder greta thundberg began
her career as a climate activist when
she was a teenager 15 16 she's now 18 so
you're not hearing from greta thundberg
as much anymore because the left is
going to find some new child to exploit
it's not as interesting it doesn't make
as big a news story when they're
exploiting an 18 or 19 or 20 year old
remember what happened to the the gun
kids remember the anti-gun kids
now i even forget the guy's name
david hogg david hogg right you don't
you don't hear from him anymore because
when he was a little kid a little kid he
was 16 17. when he was a minor the left
exploited him for their political
purposes now that he's in college he's
no use to them so he kind of goes away
so so greta thundberg showed up to the
climate conference and she gave her big
rousing protest
no more exploitation of people and
nature and the planets no more
exploitation no more blah blah blah
no matter whatever they're doing inside
there
[Applause]
what's strange people are talking about
how this was vulgar and how this was
incoherent and how this was a bad look
for the climate activists out there
uh to me this sounds just like all of
the other left-wing protests
the blah blah blah blah blah blah that's
what they all sound like to me i'm like
a character in peanuts and the the
leftist protesters they are the teacher
it's just
so when they literally say that there's
really not much of a difference in terms
of what i am hearing this christmas
season deck the halls walls windows and
doors with the best deals of the year on
the award-winning ring alarm i am sure
we all know about the ring video
doorbell by now i've been talking about
it for years and years and how
incredible it is and how it makes
everyone feel safe did you know that
ring makes an award-winning alarm ring
alarm is a powerful affordable home
security system that is so easy to
install even i can do it
gives you that same peace of mind that
same high-tech
technology that you get at the ring
video doorbell it brings it to every
corner of your house so this christmas
season
do it deck the halls the walls the doors
the windows every corner of your house
with the best deals of the year on the
award
winning ring alarm go to ring.com
knowles to get a great deal on a ring
alarm security kit today this is
something that gives me peace of mind
especially when i'm traveling you know
i'm away from home it gives you peace of
mind when you're in your house when
you're at the office when you're on a
beach makes a wonderful gift ring.com
knowles what is interesting about this
to me
is
not that the protest kind of fell flat
or that it's vulgar and the vulgarity is
really not a good look or that it was
incoherent because all they were saying
is blah blah blah it's that the whole
thing was fake the whole thing is fake
who who are greta thunberg and her
followers protesting
who are these leftist activists
protesting the leftists in the climate
conference for the leftist issue that
they all agree on
there's no there's no protest everybody
involved in this thing agrees
they all want to
harp on the climate issue they all want
to use the climate issue to take away
people's choices and way of life and
traditions
so it's just a
it's play acting
okay when parents show up to school
boards and say
you've taken too much power you're
teaching my kids a bunch of crap and
we're gonna kick you out and start
educating our own kids
that's a legitimate threat to the regime
when
environmentalists show up to the
environmentalist conference and say the
same things outside the conference that
the people inside the conference are
saying
that's
that's not a threat that actually
bolsters the regime it's the appearance
of political opposition when in fact all
of them are on the same team i'm so glad
that you liked that clip i liked that
clip too darn it
if you want more of those clips you can
ring the bell subscribe you will i hope
get notifications probably knowing these
people you probably won't but
you'll be more likely to get
notifications and you can go over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play
myspace xanga livejournal wherever you
get your audio podcasts subscribe to the
michael knowles show we will see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you